in 2007 Border Patrol agents apprehended
nearly 900,000 people they seized 950
tons of narcotics and confiscated
fifteen thousand vehicles now these are
impressive numbers but many people are
concerned that we're not doing nearly
enough to secure our 2,000 miles
southern border eighty-five percent of
which has no barrier at all the Border
Patrol cages are overworked under meant
unappreciative I'm that added eyes and
ears of the Border Patrol don't have
they don't have the manpower to set up a
static observation point in a very
critical section of the border and
that's what we're looking at this goes
on every day every night abri la hoz
open your eyes this is a reality and
you're looking at it as we speak now you
stay there lava knows love a nose we're
looking at here is the interest to an
unmonitored unchecked entrance/exit
between America and Mexico this is a
heavily traveled area where's the Border
Patrol
see you guys soon federales over there
stop us from entering that great nation
[ __ ] would you like to go for a walk to
America hey follow me I will take you to
America it's just this at fault they can
bring pounds of heroin across this
border anytime they want what's to keep
them from bringing pals of weapons-grade
uranium across this border any time they
wanted and now we got a problem but then
it's going to be too late America there
is more violence and death along the
border than ever before and hundreds of
thousands of people continue to enter
our country illegally each year it's no
wonder that immigration policy is one of
the most heated debates of our era we're
not going to be able to deal with the 12
million people who are living in the
shadows and give them a way of getting
out of the shadows if we don't also deal
with the problem of this constant influx
of undocumented workers I believe the
majority of Hispanics share our view
that the border must be secured and the
border must be secured first the
migrants are contributing to the economy
of this country whether it's the money
that goes into Social Security the taxes
they pay when they buy food produce
property these borders have to be secure
we're at war if these people in America
don't like us in Beirut or Baghdad or
wherever rat hey bring the troops back
and put them on the border between
Tijuana and Matamoros stop the flood
across the border put troops with guns
here they got guns they shoot at me all
the time let's promote human rights and
practice them we need to take this wall
down we should be working with Mexico
building bridges of communication and
not triple fences of separation jihad is
real folks when I'm telling you about
dragging out your prayer brankin you
better make things happen on this border
or you better go buy one because that's
where we're headed our country is headed
on a tailspin to hell had the wall been
built on some
from the Pacific Ocean all the way to
the globe of Mexico 2,000 miles
September 11th would have happened
exactly the same way there is no debate
however about why people want to come to
the United States everybody seems to
want to come from Mexico are other
countries the United States to chase the
American dream their risk their lives
because they're trying to feed their
families the guys that are coming to
this country I have compassion for my
understand I do I totally understand
what if I was over there I'd have been
here decades ago I promote immigration
legally these people that are crossing
over around under have no way to get
into the country legally because poor
people do not get visas that's the
biggest misinformation that's out there
another thing people have cut in front
of lines there is no line for these
people and it's like so frustrating
now one way out of this mess would be to
simply allow peaceful workers to enter
our country through legal ports of entry
if we did that we could stimulate our
economy bring a huge underground labor
market out into the open and we could
put unscrupulous smugglers out of
business more importantly we free up
Border Patrol resources that could be
used to fight criminals and terrorism if
on the other hand we want to make
securing the border our highest priority
which is what most politicians seem to
be talking about we'd be wise to emulate
communist East Germany the Berlin Wall
was built out of reinforced concrete and
patrolled by armed guards with orders to
shoot defectors in the berlin wall's
28-year existence only 5,000 people
escaped to freedom and only 200 people
died trying
for reason TV I'm drew Carey